the jurogan experience so what are you
telling me jamie
there's a ufo yesterday yeah uh nfl
popular quarterback where
for the cleveland browns former number
one pick and heisman winner yeah i think
he lives in austin
in the offseason and he uh saw a
potential ufo last night he says he says
almost hundred percent
m and i just saw ufo drop straight down
the sky
on our way home from dinner we stopped
and looked at each other
and asked if either of us saw it very
bright ball of light going straight
down out of the sky towards lake travis
could have been a drone hmm could have
been some kids
he's a football player yeah are we going
to believe him because he's famous
yeah that's the only reason i just got a
lot of attention as well well he's
famous so you
you listen to his twitter i guess i
don't know have you ever seen anything
crazy
no no i i don't think crazy
um when i'm up in the mountains
sometimes camping or whatever i'll see i
feel like some shooting stars and some
yeah
stars you know fall which actually now
that i'm saying it might be a little bit
crazy so
maybe i have seen some [ __ ] i don't know
everybody wants to think they did right
i want to think i've seen something
crazy
but i definitely haven't i thought i did
when i was a kid but now i think i was
probably lying
yeah you know when i think about it when
i was a kid i was probably full of [ __ ]
i probably wanted to you know i'm saying
like i probably saw like a military jet
and i thought and i wanted it to be
something cool like i remember the first
time i ever saw a stealth bomber we were
filming fear factor and it was over palm
palmdale which is near edwards air force
base if i didn't know
what that was i would 100 think that was
from another planet yeah you know when
you see the
thing black wing flying overhead it's
like it's pretty badass yeah
yeah i don't think i would you know i
think that my brain would just
immediately be like
ah something can explain that yeah you
know yeah
well that's the problem with anything
like that it's like it's the idea that
you're looking at something from another
planet is so
it's so outside of what you see every
day
you don't know where to put it it's
getting less outside though right right
it's getting less outside which is where
it is what's up with the uh
because i remember you saying something
about it on the podcast what's up with
that bill that passed that said that the
yeah they have to release whatever
information they have to release about
it's the covet relief bill and inside
the coveted relief bill
they gave i think it was the cia they
gave the central intelligence agency
and eighty days or something like that
to release all the information
that they have about ufos where where
are we at on that
i don't know it's a good question what
day are we on they're not they don't
have to release no
yeah they're not saying that they go oh
this is what we got we got a blurry
picture get the [ __ ] out of my house
yeah we're not gonna know anything yeah
the idea that they're gonna tell these
senators and all these elected people
what they know they're not telling them
[ __ ] unless
the aliens told them that they have 180
days to tell everyone
maybe right now you're talking if trump
didn't tell everybody
we're not gonna know yeah you know yeah
that's true i think
i remember when chris rock was talking
about obama and he was talking about
obama
people were disappointed in obama's
first administration and he said you got
to wait until
the second term and that's when you do
some really gangster [ __ ]
and obama didn't do any gangster in the
second term but
if trump got elected again in 2024
because you can only do it twice if he
got elected again in 2024
maybe he would tell us you know
recount the votes maybe he was gay maybe
he could
get on tv and that's the first [ __ ] he
talks about right away
here's what i say here's what the uh
okay include
included as a committee comment on the
intelligence authorization act the
committee
directs the director of the national
intelligence
in cons consultation with the secretary
of defense and the heads of such
other agencies to submit a report within
180 days the date of enactment
of the act to the congressional
intelligence and armed services
committees on uaps why why can't they
just say ufos
unidentified aerial phenomenon what's
the difference
unidentified flying object they got
tired of using that so they changed it
to uap
why they gotta [ __ ] with us i don't know
man uap words change all the time
they have to catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience